nous sommes au salon du golf c'est la vo
dernier salon du golf avant la ryder cup
il y en aura un en 2018 évidemment et à
l'entrée de ce salon il ya le stock de
la fédération française de golf avec
sept couples c'est la coupe que
soulèvera le vainqueur de l'open de
france avec son nouveau sponsor
hachette a alors nous allons vous faire
visiter un petit peu ce salon du golf
avec quelques stands avec quelques
invités qui défendent notamment la
france dans le golfe
et ça s'appelle par 78
invité dans cette émission spéciale
salon du golf xavier bataille il a fondé
troubles m il ya 40 ans son entreprise
est devenue le leader du marché du
chariot du golfe c'est l'un des rares
industriels français qui comptent dans
le monde du golf
rencontre avec un entrepreneur et un
innovateur passionnés longtemps numéro
un français c'est l'un de nos grands
champions de golf
aujourd'hui il dirige l'enseignement
pour le compte de bluegreen le premier
gestionnaire de parcours de golf en
france gérées watine aidant par 78 cet
ancien journaliste à créer une sorte de
michelin du golfe avec ses 5 étoiles et
les autres c'est le guide gold star il
s'appelle stéphane koudou il est l'un
des dix clubs makers les plus réputés au
monde et pourtant il est français qui
s'appelle andré tahon et préfère de loin
le sur mesure au prêt à porter
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup d'américains de japonais
dans le monde de gaulle payait aussi des
entreprises françaises c'est le cas de
troubles m une maison qui était fondée
par xavier bataille et qui est
spécialisé dans les chariots de golf et
a beaucoup de chariot de golf vais aller
retrouver xavier bataille mais je
voulais vous montrer cette invention
qu'est qu'on doit un inventeur qui est
de castres c'est la station de nettoyage
de chariots de route chariot de golf et
j'espère qu'elle va être installé dans
tous les golfs de france parce que c'est
une avancée absolument génial alors
regardez vous placez votre chariot dans
ce module est et après il ya plus qu'à
appuyer sur le bouton et le chariot va
être propre comme s'il était neuf
[Musique]
je suis donc avec xavier bataille qui
est le fondateur et le pdg de troubles m
problème c'est une marque que tous les
golfeurs connaisse qui fait des chariots
de golf c'est un des seuls français
d'ailleurs qui est dans dans l'industrie
du golf alors les batailles vous avez
commencé il ya 40 ans mais vous avez
commencé dans un autre domaine que le
golf effectivement il ya quarante ans
que 3m existe nous avons démarré notre
carrière avec des chariots pour planche
à voile et comme on a allégé les
planches à voile à une certaine époque
il a fallu faire autre chose et c'est à
ce moment là qu'on a commencé à
développer le golf
c'était en 83 il y avait moins de
soixante mille licenciés
c'est un pari un petit peu risqué mais
finalement notre activité nous a permis
de nous développer de passer du chariot
manuels aux chariots électriques
une dizaine d'années plus tard avant de
devenir
le leader incontesté sur ce marché
aujourd'hui ya ce qui est apprécié aussi
il ya beaucoup d'innovations dans le
marché du chariot et dans l'invention du
sérieux des chariots vous sortez combien
de modèles nouveau presque par année
alors notre objectif est de sortir un
modèle un modèle et demi minimum chaque
année pourquoi
parce qu'on veut toujours avoir un
chariot l'avancent bien évidemment et on
essaye de répondre aux exigences des
clients
nous avons commencé à faire des chariots
électriques en 93
on a été sacrés meilleurs produits du
marché en 98 par golf européen
et c'est à partir de ce moment là que la
marque problème a commencé à vraiment
prendre des parts de marché importantes
vous aimez évidemment commencer par les
ballets sérieux manuel et puis sont
arrivés les chariots électriques aussi
là on est frappé par l'innovation dans
ce domaine
l'innovation ça a commencé avec
l'arrivée de la batterie lithium oui
effectivement à une époque on utilisait
des batteries plomb extrêmement lourde
qui pose est pratiquement le poids du
chariot ont été obligés d'avoir des
structures beaucoup plus solide pour
qu'au chariot résiste sur tout type de
parcours
aujourd'hui avec des chariots qui font
environ 1 kg non seulement on est plus
performant on a plus d'autonomie mais on
a des structures de chariots qui sont
extrêmement légères et qui nous
permettent d'avoir des poids avoisinant
les chariots manuel donc c'est un
progrès considérable
l'objectif pour les clients c'est un un
chariot qui soit dans un niveau de prix
abordable 2 qui soit suffisamment
compact pour le ranger soit dans son
coffre de voiture soit chez soi et la
troisième c'est qui est un grand confort
d'utilisation
alors ça c'est sur le plan technique
mais il ya aussi le nerf de la guerre
qui est le service
on est capable aujourd'hui de prendre en
garantie
et de réparer un chariot en moins de
trois jours
c'est à dire qu'un client qui tombe en
panne sur tous nos chariots
on a un logo troubles m assistance
les personnes peuvent se rendre dans
leur magasin où peuvent appeler
directement trop l'ama sistance comprend
directement le chariot en charge chez la
personne
il est rapatrié à l' usine est réparé et
est reparti chez les clients en moins de
48 heures donc c'est une d'excellentes
performances et aujourd'hui on a des
transporteurs très efficace et ce qui
contribue à la notoriété de problèmes
bien évidemment nous employer
aujourd'hui une dizaine de salariés
vous êtes à bové donc on produit
français s'il veut dans un village à
côté de beauvais au peu de repos donnait
le chiffre d'affaires de la société où
effectivement problème est une petite
pme et nous réalisons un chiffre
d'affaires un peu un petit peu supérieur
à 3 millions d'euros
donc c'est voilà quarante ans c'est un
bel anniversaire ses 40 ans de problème
donc 40 ans c'est vrai que
je suis plus prêt de la sortie que de
l'entrée mais je suis un passionné et
mon métier c'est vraiment de créer des
concepts et d'apporter un réel service
pour faire de la marque problème une
marque qui soit à la hauteur de
l'exigence des clients c'est évident
voilà acheter français et donc avait
avec avait avec troubles m
alors sans livrer de secret industriel à
vos concurrents parce que je sais qu'il
vous explique beaucoup
est ce qu'on peut savoir sur quoi vous
travaillez aujourd'hui pour les pour les
mois ou les années qui viennent
bien évidemment on est connu pour
l'innovation permanente en 2017
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
la motorisation d'un chariot manuel nous
développons une roue motrice qui se
fixera à la vente nos chariots et qui
permettra avec une petite télécommande
de pouvoir faire avancer son chariot
sans peine non plus de câble put
potentiomètre plus de le contacteur un
système simple efficace et j'en suis sûr
donnera le le goût
au golfeur de ne pas revenir en arrière
et de passer sur un chariot
traditionnelle par la suite
oui en quelque sorte de chariot
électrique pour tous et il ya une autre
innovation
oui on a beaucoup de golfeurs
vieillissant qui ont les petits pran de
santé donc qu'ils sont obligés
d'utiliser une voiture est à chaque
parcours on considère que c'est un
budget important ils nous le disent
donc on a réfléchi à une solution
efficace
non que nous développons un scooter en
pliable qui se mettra dans un coffre de
voiture
quelque chose de léger et qui permettra
avec un prix tout à fait modique de
pouvoir continuer à jouer au golf en
toute quiétude
voilà il ya beaucoup encore dit de vinci
à venir merci beaucoup merci infiniment
xavier bataille et glauque vie à troll m
ce
je vous propose de retrouver maintenant
quelqu'un que j'admire beaucoup c'est un
grand champion de golf
il était très longtemps du numéro un
français il est un des responsables
aujourd'hui de la société blue green
sait gérer watine syrie watine bonjour
et aujourd'hui vous êtes vous êtes à
blues et vous êtes un des dirigeants de
bluegreen oui effectivement je suis en
charge notamment de tous qui enseigne
mans donc je manage les pros et je mets
en place également tous les produits
d'enseignement pour tous les publics
alors blue green c'est une quarantaine
de golf en france
oui un peu plus 49 exactement et puis
des partenariats avec beaucoup de golf
en france et à l'étranger
alors je le disais vous avez été numéro
1 français vous êtes un grand champion
de golf mais il ya une vie après la
carrière sportive proprement dit et vous
êtes un des exemples d'une vie réussie
après la carrière de deux sports de
sport de haut niveau
ça s'est passé très simplement parce qu
en fait moi j'ai toujours adoré
l'enseignement j'ai travaillé pour la
fédération française de golf et je
m'occupais du haut niveau à la
fédération
donc tout ce qui touche à l'enseignement
me plaît beaucoup donc ça est s'est fait
assez naturellement en fait vous avez
mettez quelques années sur le circuit
dits seniors 1
vous avez d'ailleurs remporté pas mal de
pas mal de titres ya une différence
quand même quand on joue les grands
championnats comme vous l'avez fait puis
le circuit senior c'est plus
décontractée ah oui c'est nettement plus
décontracté parce qu'on a
j'ai envie de dire plus rien à prouver
et puis c c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
très sympathique on retrouve des vieux
copains
et puis c'est beaucoup axé aussi sur les
pro am donc on rencontre beaucoup de
gens qui sont dans la vie active et on
passe des très très bon moment vous avez
été responsable de l'enseignement de
haut niveau à la fédération française de
golf et là on voit émerger aujourd'hui
quelques français sur lesquels vous
comptez pas ce qu'on va arriver à la
ryder cup on est parmi eux il y aura un
français bas ce qui est sympa c'est que
depuis quelques années justement si on
dit qu'elle est celui qui va percer et
ben on a on a plusieurs choix
alors qu'il ya quelques années on en
avait pas et donc ça c'est un vrai
avantage on a
alexander levy qui va bien il ya bien
que tu as bien sûr victor dubuisson qui
quiberon qui est plus mais lui c'est un
peu des hauts des bas mais on à romain
langue ask qui commencent à arriver et
des tas de jeunes qui arrivent et ça
c'est vraiment très bien
alors vous avez un pronostic est ce que
vous pensez qu'il y aura un français
dans l'équipe de la ryder cup
alors non seulement je l'espère mais je
pense que oui je pense que oui parce que
on a pas mal de jeunes qui vont bien et
je pense que alors moi personnellement
je parierais pour langage couler vie
alors on viendra vous voir dans un arbre
faut savoir c'est si ça va alors
revenons quand même à un blue green ne
vous disait qu'à 49 golf 49 gaulle qui
sont ouverts au public c'est ça la
particularité de bruyn oui alors ce nous
c'est beaucoup des délégations de
service public c'est à dire c'est
souvent des golfs qui sont qui sont
publiques donc qui appartiennent à et
des collectivités et que nous gérons
pour eux en fait c'est notre métier
alors après on gère également pour des
privés et nous en avons quatre ans en
propriétés propres
alors un jour parisienne par exemple
connais évidemment saint quentin en
yvelines
bahia n'a rien n'a beaucoup d'autres il
ya il ya des très beaux cols comme
seignosse on a également pléneuf val
andré on a des golfs aussi dans le sud
est
on a pas mal de golf un peu partout en
france donc c'est tout et c'est une des
plus grosses sociétés de gestion de
gestion de golf
est-ce que vous avez disait
vécu le haut niveau vous regrettez un
peu d'être arrivé peut-être un petit peu
trop tôt de pouvoir participer de pas
avoir pu participer à l'événement comme
comme la ryder cup en france
oui j'ai envie de dire quelque part oui
pour des tas de raisons
et puis moi à l'époque où je jouais en
fait c'était un match qui se passait
entre les îles britanniques et les états
unis et donc nous le continent pouvait
pas et on ne pouvait pas atteindre cette
sélection l'a en tout cas et le fait que
ça vienne en 98 va mieux vaut tard que
jamais j'ai envie de dire mais c'est un
énorme événement pour la france et ça
c'est super merci infiniment zéro at il
est bien encore toute notre admiration
pour tout ce que vous avez fait dans le
golfe excuses pour tout ce que vous
faites pour le golf alors il ya les
golfeurs il est spécialiste du matériel
de golf et puis il ya des artistes et je
suis ravi d'être de vous présenter des
toiles d'andré marc serrano andré marc
serrano c'est un peintre qui consacre
une partie de son oeuvre
havas au golf qui l'inspirent pourrez le
retrouver sur sur internet et l'étoile
d'or et marc serrano qui sont absolument
formidable et à propos de à propos d'
artiste on va retrouver aussi un
sculpteur qui s'évalue baer privée sur
son stand on va parler avec quelqu'un
qui fait un guide des golfs comme il ya
un guide michelin avec des étoiles
c'est stéphane koudou mais voici
quelqu'un qui n'arrête pas c'est hubert
privé le sculpteur du golfe on s'était
vus pour le dernier numéro 2 par 78 et
là je vois qui est une nouvelle création
vous êtes vous n'arrêtez pas quoi ah oui
bien en fait depuis qu'on s'est vus j'ai
travaillé quand même sur l'actualité
notre actualitté golfique en france
puisque on a la chance donc d'avoir
comme sponsor titre maintenant l'open de
france à schena et donc j'ai souhaité
faire un clin d'oeil de bienvenue à
cette entreprise chinoise pour avoir un
open de france d'avec une dotation
incroyable qui va nous permettre d'avoir
vraiment les très grands joueurs et
c'est vrai que bravo à à l'european tour
et bravo à la fédé pour cette initiative
et bravo à vous pour pour ce pti hn1
cède 1
est-ce que nous prêtons riez quelques
quelques minutes votre stand
parce que franchement de stéphane
koudougou savez de gaulle star vous
connaissez bien
ah ben oui mais c'est bien sûr avec
grand plaisir vous êtes chez vous ici
patricia pas de souci merci mr là
stéphane courbon jours alors pour ceux
qui ne sais pas je vous présente les a
été journaliste à l'express vous êtes et
alcool gazzin golf européen et puis il
ya quelques années vous avez fondé coop
star
l'idée était de classifier les golfs
comme on classifie l'hôtellerie en
france et j'espère bien en europe et
dans le monde entier
alors ce saut il faut le dire les
étoiles ce sont des critères objectifs
viennent 200 ch 245 critères pour un 18
trous tout à fait en fait on a travaillé
avec toutes les instances nationales et
fédérales pga effet golf adf arf
ministère du tourisme et on a établi
deux cent quarante cinq critères que les
directeurs peuvent cocher ou pas en
fonction de leur objectivité de leurs
services et équipements alors si je veux
par exemple le jouer dans les yvelines
je peux regarder évidemment dans le
guidon je peux aller sur votre site
tout à fait vous pouvez à loisir et de
façon gratuite puisque l'abonnement est
gratuit
vous pouvez sélectionner 126000 données
sur les golfs donc vous pouvez cliquer
sur yvelines où le golf de saint nom la
bretèche ou le l'académie du tremblay
sur mauldre etc et vous avez l'ensemble
des critères sachant que pour les neuf
trous on est sur 102 critères et pour
les 18 trous et plus nous sommes sur 245
critères tous objectif sur les yvelines
vous avez quads et des cinq étoiles
oui alors nous avons trois parcours 5
étoiles qui sont le prieuré saint nom la
bretèche et le bloc national bien
évidemment avec le à shannon de france
qui arrive puisque vous étiez avec mon
ami hubert
ensuite on passe très vite à des quatre
étoiles et vous retrouver une partie des
de la chaîne you golf avec bêtement vous
avez du neuf du neuf trous 4 étoiles qui
est le domaine du tremblay sur mauldre
après on va pas des pas tous les
pêcheurs pas tous les 30 ball delà de la
yg de paris bien évidemment référencés
sur golf ça puisqu'on travaille avec la
fédé pour cela donc c'est très simple il
suffit de s'inscrire en fin de s'abonner
gaulle ça tout à fait absolument
s'inscrit gratuitement en deux clics
c'était un mail et un mot de passe et de
la si vous souhaitez vous pouvez ensuite
aller sur mon compte et remplir votre
profil golfeurs et on fait des jeux
régulièrement pour savoir qui vous êtes
pour mieux cerner vos attentes vos
habitudes
et puis y ait une autre initiative que
vous avez fait avec des habits ce solide
ça fait penser aux tontons flingueurs
mais ça s'appelle les tontons golfeur
alors l'idée ses quatre copains on a
quatre compétences complémentaires et on
n'a pas envie de se prendre trop au
sérieux
on s'est dit pourquoi on montrait pas
une association comprendra un grand
stand sur le salon l'année dernière gold
star avait un stand de 20 mètres carrés
cette année on est quatre on a 120
mètres carrés
on vous attend d'ailleurs avec le
simulateur et le concours de putting et
on va lancer des programmes vraiment
nouveau
très haut de gamme qui vont nous
permettre déjà pour commencer sur la
région parisienne et sur deauville de
faire une offre différente est vraiment
nouvelle
lors de ces programmes on est ravis
d'accueillir maserati maserati va mettre
une maserati entrons en un sur chaque
compétition mais nous servirons du
caviar du whisky haut de gamme beaucoup
de choses très très très haut de gamme
je rappelle qu'elle magazine qui
l'actualité du golfe a fusé dans tous
les clubs de 100 km autour de paris et
on le sort tous les trimestres
donc là le numéro de printemps le 21
mars sera à disposition dans tous les
clubs d'île de france
dépêchez vous d'aller chercher parce
qu'on en met entre 100 et 3 cents par
part golfe
donc du coup dépêchez vous d'aller
chercher pour ceux qui sont intéressés
il peut y en avoir pour tout le monde
mais faut faire vite
vous avez le guide en vente sur le site
on a aussi un club je viens de vous en
parler on a un club de membres de gaulle
star ou là on offre le guide on offre
des balles de golf callaway douze balles
et ce club vous permet d'avoir des tas
davantage merci infiniment stéphane
ledoux
[Musique]
voici maintenant notre rubrique
matériels
je vais les rejoindre un français qui
fait des clubs sur mesure il s'appelle
andré tahon je suis en compagnie de
quelqu'un qui porte haut les couleurs de
la france dans le golfe puisque c'est un
des meilleurs breakers dans le monde
c'est à dire de qui assemble les clubs
c'est andrée t ou bonjour
alors oui on va essayer d'être d'abord
de dire qu'est ce que c'est votre métier
alors mon métier c'est pas de vendre des
clubs de golf
mon métier c'est avant tout un métier de
prestataire de service c'est-à-dire cdh
assembler des composants deux clubs de
golf en fonction des carpes capacités
physiques de la morphologie des
capacités golfique des golfeurs de
manière à optimiser l'ensemble des clubs
dont ils disposeront mais la priorité
c'est avant tout ce n'est pas du tout
telle ou telle marque
c'est avant tout les réglages que nous
allons faire payer ce qui existe dans
l'est dans les bagarres dans les clubs
il ya le fitting qui est la différence
entre le physique est ce que vous faites
la différence fondamentale c'est que
quand vous achetez des clubs dans un
magasin vous allez acheter des clubs de
marquer ces clubs de barques
ils sont déjà pré assemblés alors on va
pouvoir à partir de la modifier un ou
deux paramètres peut-être 3 mais on ne
modifiera jamais les douze ou treize
paramètres qui en réalité peuvent être
réglés sur un club de golf et sur un
ensemble de clubs de golf
je prends en achetant par exemple
l'exemple du driver l'exemple du driver
tout à l'heure j'avais un monsieur qui
me dit j'ai j'avance pas beaucoup aux
drivers
j'ai meilleur résultat avec mon bois 3
qu'est ce que vous en pensez et où je
sais pas si je vous vois pas je peux pas
vous dire mais est ce que vous
connaissez votre vie thème de swing ah
non je sais pas ce que je dis pas ce que
vous savez si vous connaissez votre
vitesse de ce oui moi je peux vous dire
quel est votre distance optimale au
drive et si je m'occupe de vous faire un
driver et que je n'obtiens pas pour vous
cette distance optimale
je ne serais pas content donc vous
repartirez pas avec un dragueur de chez
moi parce que le but c'est vraiment ça
il ya là encore c'est pas de je pense
que je crois que etc vous avez telle
vitesse vous avez tel angle d'attaqué
vous avez telle distance potentiel voyez
c'est comme ça que ça marche
par exemple si on prend un driver il ya
combien de critères qu'il faudrait
établir pour avoir les drivers idée
alors si vous voulez un driver c'est le
club le plus difficile à bien régler et
c'est souvent le plus mal réglée
d'ailleurs pour cette raison là quand
vous prenez la longueur vous prenez
l'angle de la face vous prenez le loft
vous prenez le shaft ou prenez le poids
du shaft vous prenez le profil du shaft
vous prenez l'equilibre du club vous
vous faites une combinaison de tous ces
paramètres
vous arrivez en tout cas chez un club
mais coeur à une possibilité de 1
million cinq cent quarante mille et
quelques combinaisons
donc ça veut dire que si vous sortez
d'un magasin avec un driver qui vous est
vraiment adapté
ben c'est accepter votre jour de chance
alors il ya beaucoup d'instruments
évidemment 12 séries là on a une sorte
de balance ça sert à quoi
alors ces ballons ça swingue weight vous
avez les mêmes dans le monde entier
alors elle peut avoir des design un peu
différent mais le principe est le même
ça permet de mesurer l'équilibré du club
la seule chose c'est que ça c'est un
équilibre statique teint hâlé d'alors le
club il est à l'arrêt là ils bougent
plus une fois qui est en équilibre
or quand vous swing est un club bien
évidemment vous n'êtes pas du tout
statique et notamment au moment où vous
relâcher les poignets le club prend son
envol la force qui s'applique au club
varient très très vite en fonction de la
longueur c'est très simple regardez si
je prends ce club ici et que j'essaye de
l'agité par là c'est très facile je le
fais entre deux doigts si je le prends
ici où c'est beaucoup plus difficile
voilà alors c'est ce phénomène qui est à
l'oeuvre et qui fait que quand vous avez
comme est un club un mobile au tournant
en rotation autour d'un axe si vous
voulez avoir les mêmes sensations de
club en club vous devez le régler en
moment d'inertie qui vous donnera des
sensations beaucoup plus homogène donc
on voit que la scène c'est vraiment un
réglage très précis c'est donc c'est du
sur mesure
il ya une chose qui est importante sur
laquelle vous insistez c'est que les
clubs quelles que soient leurs auteurs
et il ya des fers numéro 3 ou un wedge
par exemple il arrive on a la même prise
au swing oui c'est à dire que depuis
alors là depuis 11 ans pratiquement
jamais pris pour habitude lors sauf si
le golfeur ne voulait pas mais je
prendrai peut-être un ou deux qui n'a
pas voulu qu'on fasse comme ça réglez
les clubs de telle sorte que vous ayez
toujours quelle que soit la longueur du
fer c'est uniquement les faire entre eux
la même posture à l'adresse c'est à dire
qu'on joue un petit peu sur la longueur
un petit peu sur le lay et vous avez
toujours la même posture à l'adresse et
en même temps bien évidemment vous avez
le même moment d'inertie tels que je
vous l'expliquais tout à l'heure donc ça
va donner des clubs sur lesquels vous
aurez toujours la même posture à
l'adresse la même sensation dans le
swing est bien évidemment ça va
contribuer à vous donner un jeu plus
régulier parce que ce que vous faites en
faisant ça c'est purement et simplement
vous éliminer des facteurs de dispersion
et c'est ça ce qui est important dans le
gain à plus de régularité dans le golfe
bien sûr elle ajouté commentant un
réglage aussi qu'on ne pourrait pas
faire avec des clubs acheter d'aude dans
l'oeil de deux marques et je vais vous
montrer par exemple ici vous avez un
club qui a un lay classique s'il voulait
un stand à aux proches de ce standard
est là celui qui est derrière
c'est le même c'est celui de ma femme
n'est qu'un loyer que la différence de
l'ail est absolument énorme
c'est à dire que entre les deux il y à
il ya plus de 5 degrés
à 6 degrés de différence de l'aïe alors
ça ça se fait comment ça se fait en
tordant si vous voulez le aux ailes ici
et le tort dans cette proportion
c'est totalement impossible avec un
quelconque love grand public que vous
pourrez trouver ici ou là puis alors par
ailleurs comme ce club il est quand même
assez court pour qu'ils aient quand un
malgré tout un équilibre satisfaisant
bien évidemment j'ai dû remettre
beaucoup de poids dans la tête parce
qu'autrement il aurait paru beaucoup
trop léger et ça je peux le faire parce
que les composants que j'utilise si vous
voulez bénéficient tous d'un petit slot
ici à de petits logements dans lequel je
vais mettre des poids et qui va me
permettre de régler parfaitement
l'équilibré pour faire une série à la
fois agréable à jouer et complètement
homogène du début jusqu'à la fin
oui bon ça c'est très important eh bien
merci beaucoup andré table alors je
disais vous attendez des globes meilleur
français le club poker français un des
meilleurs au monde et vous portez parce
que nos fossés des clubs sur mesure que
vous faites donc c'est le luxe français
qui fait qui inquiète et dans le off
merci beaucoup voudraient tabou
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite preneurs aux livres ou deux
par 78
[Musique]